bon
[Musique]
je vous propose de vous emmener sur la
route des châteaux des yvelines il y en
a une vingtaine dans le département et
nous en avons sélectionné trois à ces
partis
[Musique]
première escale le château de
monte-cristo port-marly cet ancien
vignoble a été transformée par
l'écrivain alexandre dumas à la moitié
du 19e siècle
présentation de ce style néo renaissance
[Musique]
non
à mots pour caractériser ce château ils
portent toute l'âme d'alexandre dumas
je crois que c'est ça qui caractérise
monte cristo essentiellement et que ce
qui fait sa spécificité
selon elle le château est sculpté de
toutes parts vous pourrez voir des
visages d'écrivains des sculptures
diverses des instruments de musique des
armes des des personnages mi ange mi
végétaux des bouquets de fleurs des
bouquets de fruits face et c'est très
étonnant
il faut lire la façade du château
aujourd'hui il fait très beau on peut se
promener dans les jardins c'est aussi ça
qui fait la beauté du lieu
oui bien sûr le château est inscrit dans
un parc romantique aménagé à l'anglais
avec des grottes des rocailles des
cascades c'est vraiment un vrai bonheur
de se promener là et vous organiser des
événements également pendant cet été
cet été nous avons une exposition d'art
contemporain qui est installée au
deuxième étage du château il faut venir
voir des oeuvres très étonnante d'un
artiste américain qui s'appelle à doute
jamal merci beaucoup frédéric il
résister tout ça
[Musique]
là
deuxième étape de notre périple après le
style néo renaissance place au style
médiéval
[Applaudissements]
o o
angoua des ruines mais est ce qu'il est
vraiment ruines alors effectivement
lorsqu'on s'approche de ce château on a
vraiment l'impression d'un tas de ruine
envahie par la végétation défaut quand
même que vous sachiez que ce château
déjà un peu plus de mille ans d'histoire
il fut forteresse médiévale il a été
ensuite résidence royale est aujourd'hui
effectivement il nous donne cette image
un petit peu délabré bien sûr il y à
toute l'histoire qui est passé par ces
ruines mais il est toujours vivant il
est toujours debout et son histoire est
particulièrement intéressante il un
avantage également c'est qu'il est
gratuit si on veut venir pour visiter
autour on peut le voir tout à fait nous
sommes l'association qui nous occupons
particulièrement du château nous
assurons des visites pour des groupes
constitués ou bourthes et rendez vous
mais surtout pour les journées du
patrimoine le dimanche des journées du
patrimoine il sera ouvert à tous le
public de 10h à 18h le soir gratuitement
et là nous faisons des visites racontant
l'histoire de ce grand château
[Musique]
troisième étape de notre périple le
donjon de houdan qui datent du 12e
siècle on va le visiter
alors
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut visiter ici
dans le donjon de houdan alors on peut
visiter une exposition toute l'année sur
le donjon de dents sur son histoire sur
ces différentes occupations et une
utilisation au cours des siècles mais on
peut aussi visiter des expositions
temporaires en ce moment une exposition
sur les chouettes jusqu'à la fin août
c'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir le
patrimoine des yvelines oui le donjon de
houdan c'est un monument historique de
la fin du xiième siècle
il a été rénové récemment et il est
ouvert au public depuis trois ans
maintenant et combien ça coûte ça coûte
4 euros pour les adultes 2 euros pour
les enfants jusqu'à 6 ans et c'est
gratuit pour les enfants de moins de 6
ans
avec ces trois visites j'espère que je
vous ai donné envie de découvrir le
patrimoine chinois si vous avez encore
des questions rendez vous sur le site
internet divine tourisme moi je vais
continuer encore un petit peu les
visites
[Musique]